Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Wir wollen endlich mal wieder auf die Europäischen Top-Ligen blicken. Es wird die allerhöchste Zeit für die erste Ligatour dieser Saison, 2022-23. Und die hört ihr jetzt hier in Rasenfunk Kurzpass 227. Ich begrüße euch ganz herzlich hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Hallo liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Wir sprechen hier über die Europäischen Top-Ligen und haben deswegen auch wieder eine ganze Reihe von tollen Gästen hier. Ich begrüße zum einen Alexis Menuge. Hallo Alexis.
Hallo zusammen.
Hattest du einen schönen Sommer?
Ja, kurz Urlaub gemacht im Juni und dann schon die Vorfreude auf diese fantastische Saison mit fast jeden Tag Spiele überall.
Man weiß nicht, ob man da eine Mü-Ironie gerade rausgehört hat.
Je mehr Spiele in der Champions League, desto besser.
Hatte er dann doch recht. Aber gut, Self-fulfilling prophecy vielleicht ein bisschen. Okay, das ist die Situation bei Juve. Und was haben wir bei Atalanta? Du hast geschrieben, das neue Atalanta. Was ist denn alles neu bei Atalanta?
Ja, also erstens Atalanta, Punkt gleich mit Napoli und Milan an der Spitze. Das war auch nicht unbedingt zu erwarten nach der letzten Saison, weil da ist doch ein bisschen was von diesem Atalanta-Zauber verflogen, der ja einige Jahre angehalten hat. Ich finde, also klar, ergebnistechnisch keine Frage. Sie haben es nicht mal geschafft, sich international zu qualifizieren. Deswegen ganz klar. Aber sie waren in der letzten Saison auch nicht schlecht. Also was ihnen gefehlt hat, war oft im letzten Drittel. Sie haben es immer wieder geschafft, Chancen zu kreieren, viele Leute in die gefährliche Zone zu bringen. Aber dann hat es einfach daran gehapert, dass sie ihre Tore nicht gemacht haben. Das lag daran, dass Zapata lange verletzt war. Allgemein war da so ein bisschen der Wurm drin. Am Ende standen sie da ohne Europapokal teilnehmen. Deswegen war jetzt im Sommer schon die Frage, was passiert jetzt mit Atalanta? Gasparini gab es so ein paar Aussagen. Da war ja auch der Eigentümerwechsel. Da ist jetzt auch eine amerikanische Gruppe dahinter. Gasparini meinte, wir müssen mal reden und schauen, ob das noch passt. Irgendwie hat man das Gefühl, das Zauber ist verflogen. Sie haben sich jetzt im Sommer verjüngt. Das war meiner Meinung nach ein sehr guter Schritt. Sie haben Heulund vorne, einen jungen Mann aus Graz, für den sie tief in die Tasche gegriffen haben. Ein junger dänischer Stürmer, der jetzt auch schon einmal getroffen hat. Sie haben Lukman geholt, den man aus Leipzig noch kennt. Sie haben Ederson geholt von der Salernitana im zentralen Mittelfeld, 23 Jahre jung. Sie haben Soppi geholt auf außen, 20 Jahre jung. Und hinten Orcoli, ein aufstreibender, junger italienischer Innenverteidiger, der ausgeliehen war in Kremonese, der jetzt wieder gekommen ist. Also frisches Blut. Und das tut ihnen insofern gut, weil der Stil ist weiterhin sehr aktiv, sehr physisch. Da wird marschiert, da wird Tempo gemacht. Aber sie sind defensiv viel strukturierter geworden. Also früher, wahrscheinlich viele, die sich jetzt noch an Atalanta erinnern, da war oft Krawall, also im positiven Sinne. Da war offensiv wahnsinnig viel los. Sie haben auch Räume gelassen. Und das ist jetzt in dieser Startphase, haben sie viel kontrollierter. Sie brauchen im Moment wenig. Sie hatten jetzt am Wochenende Kremonese, haben lang 1-0 geführt. Wenn sie das Spiel gewonnen hätten, dann wären sie jetzt bei 16 Punkten. Dann hätten sie nur das eine Unentschieden gegen Milan, das ziemlich beeindruckend war. Sie haben zwar noch in dem Fall später einen Ausgleich bekommen, aber sie hatten schon Spiele in der Saison, wo sie kontrolliert gespielt haben und dann irgendwann ihr Tor gemacht haben und dann die Spiele auch die meisten bisher gewonnen haben. Und wenn deswegen, wie gesagt, dazu kommt, diese Defensive, ein bisschen mehr Ausgeglichenheit, dazu frischer Wind, der da ist und weiterhin die Abläufe von Gasperini, die ja weiterhin da sind, also die Mannschaft weiß ja, was sie zu tun hat, finde ich einen spannenden Ansatz vor allen Dingen. Und das könnte halt ein entscheidender Punkt sein. Sie sind jetzt halt auch die einzigen aus diesen italienischen Top-Clubs, die nicht die Doppelbelastung haben. Wenn man sich gerade in dieser Startphase angeschaut hat, eine englische Woche nach der anderen, bei den großen teilweise schon einige muskuläre Verletzungen in Italien, wirklich auffällig. Also man hat gemerkt, dass dieser –was man in Italien nicht unterschätzen darf –die Saison ging eine Woche früher los, als gewohnt. Hat aber auch lang gedauert für viele Spieler mit Nationalmannschaft. Man hat jetzt schon mal gemerkt, das haben auch einige Serie-A-Trainer schon angesprochen, muskuläre Geschichten könnten gefährlich werden. Und du hast bei allen Top-Teams jetzt schon –dabei sind Schlüsselspieler, die fehlen –und Atalanta sind die einzigen, die sich erst mal Woche für Woche –oder logisch in der Englischen Serie –nicht diese Doppelbelastung haben. Und dadurch, dass sie weiterhin einen sehr physisch intensiven Stil spielen, sehr körperlich stark sind, hat Milan sehr zu spüren bekommen bei dem 1-1 vor Kurzem. Also Atalanta wegschieben ist weiterhin nicht so einfach, könnte jetzt schon ein Faktor werden, der ihnen zugutekommt. Dementsprechend bin ich sehr gespannt. Ich muss sagen, mich hat es überrascht, dass sie, weil sie oft auch ein bisschen Spätstarter waren, jetzt sind sie gleich schon da. Schauen, wie sich das weiterhin entwickelt. Gasperini hatte auch noch im Spätsommer Gemeinsam. Eigentlich ist das nicht die Mannschaft, die ich wollte. Ich hatte schon ein bisschen andere Ideen gehabt. Hat so ein bisschen vor sich hin gemurmelt, sage ich mal. Aber Fakt ist, jetzt ist er mittendrin. Er hat auch noch Stürmer bekommen, er hat Heulund bekommen, Luckmann bekommen. Das war auch immer so ein Thema. Er hat gesagt, seit zwei Jahren rede ich einfach ein, wir brauchen Stürmer, wir brauchen Stürmer. Jetzt hat er sie bekommen. Die haben auch beide gleich schon gut eingeschlagen. Also, spannendes Projekt. Schauen, ob Atalanta es schafft, da auch vorne dran zu bleiben.
Aber absolut. Und ich bin so dankbar, dass du hier bist, Christian, und dass ich hier immer Experten habe. Denn bei der Serie A ist es wirklich unmöglich, die Transfers zu bewerten. Atalanta hatte 64 Zugänge und 63 Abgänge. Woher soll ich erkennen, wer in diesem Wust aus Leyen vielleicht dann doch irgendwas kann? Ich habe keine Chance. Es ist einfach absolut bezahlt.
Ja, das ist ein großes Thema. Es sind ja auch ein paar, so wie einer wie Remo Freuler, der in die Premier League gewechselt ist. Also, auch logisch Identifikationsfigur, wichtiger Figur, die weg sind. Aber eben wie gesagt, sie sind jünger geworden. Und im Moment, eine Einnahme müssen wir noch nennen, Coop Miners. Der Niederländer, der letzte Saison auch schon da war.
Schon vier Tore gemacht.
Ja, herausragenden Saisonstart. Nicht nur aufgrund seiner Tore, da wirklich im zentralen Mittelfeld, da war ja ewig diese Freuler, der Ruhn, das war so das Tour, das der Land auch getragen hat. Die anderen haben Krawall gemacht, sage ich mal, im positiven Sinne, und sie haben da im Zentrum das Zentrum zugemacht. Coop Miners ist jetzt da in die Rolle mit der Ruhn perfekt rein, hat da auch noch diesen sehr, sehr guten Abschluss aus der Distanz, der schon ein paar Mal zum Tragen kam, bringt diese Füße mit, verkörpert jetzt eigentlich auch diesen Atalanta-Stil, sehr, sehr gut von Gasperini. Also ja, sehr guter Start und eben wie gesagt, sie haben die Doppelbelastung nicht.
Mensch, die Serie A, es verspricht wieder eine spannende Saison zu werden. Ich danke dir ganz herzlich, das war Christian Bernhard. Danke, dass du hier ins Rasenfunk-Hauptstudio gekommen bist. Als hätten wir neben Studios. Und ihr hört jetzt noch hier gleich das, was ich mit Fabian Pakulat zu La Liga besprochen habe. Viel Spaß damit und bitte. Jetzt wollen wir über La Liga sprechen und ich freue mich, dass Fabian Pakulat hier ist, der Ed Rosengartler. Hallo Fabian. Morgen, Abend. Es ist ja alles zeitrein im Podcastbereich. Hast du die Sommerpause gut hinter dich gebracht?
War in Deutschland, Italien, Baskenland und jetzt wieder zurück in Malaga.
Das hat sich ehrlich gesagt sogar bis auf den letzten Ort hin nach Urlaub angehört. Aber gut, das ist eben dein Leben. Ein Leben in Sonnenschein. Wir wollen über La Liga sprechen. 5 Spieltage sind bereits absolviert. Ein paar Dinge haben die Hörerinnen und Hörer bestimmt mitbekommen. Also es wird ihnen jetzt nicht entgangen sein, dass ein gewisser Robert Lewandowski bei Barca spielt. Zum Beispiel. Aber ein paar Dinge vielleicht nicht so. Und vielleicht fangen wir damit gleich mal an. Du hast drei Themen mitgebracht. Und eines davon betrifft die aktuelle Überraschungsmannschaft. Und das ist Ossasuna. Warum liegen die auf Tabellenplatz 4? Ja, okay, ist jetzt erstmal die Tabelle noch 5 Spieltagen. Aber wie konnten die so erfolgreich in die Saison starten?
Also sie haben wirklich in den letzten Jahren kontinuierlich gute Arbeit geleistet und haben einen Trainer, den ich für sehr, sehr interessant halte und sehr gut. Der heißt Yagova Arasate, ist ein Baske. Ossasuna ist ja eigentlich das Team aus Pamplona. Ossasuna ist quasi der baskische Name dafür. Und ja, ist eigentlich eher immer so ein kleiner Verein gewesen, so ein typischer Verein, der halt immer mal so zwischen erster und zweiter Liga hin und her pendelt. Sie haben jetzt aber seit, ich glaube, jetzt im zweiten Jahr ein komplett neues Stadion, ein richtig schönes Schmuckkästchen, das natürlich immer voll ist. Und ja, sie haben es tatsächlich geschafft, in den letzten Jahren gute Spieler zu halten. Am Trainer haben sie auch ziemlich lange festgehalten. Und im Moment funktioniert das richtig gut. Wie gesagt, sehr, sehr überraschend gut, dass es so auf Takt mit vier Siegen, einer Niederlage nach fünf Spielen.
Sie haben unter anderem gegen Sevilla mit 2 zu 1 gewonnen. Kann man denn am Beispiel Ossasuna etwas lernen, wie man es schaffen kann, in der La Liga, sich so langsam nach oben zu arbeiten? Also wie gesagt, natürlich müssen wir die Klammer drum machen, Fünfter Spieltag und so weiter. Und es kann sein, dass das jetzt nur eine Momentaufnahme ist. Aber die Dinge, die du angesprochen hast, das neue Stadion, das Festhalten an einem interessanten Trainer, das scheint mir ja schon etwas zu sein, was auf Längerfristigkeit hindeutet.
Ja, vielleicht kann man sogar ein bisschen vergleichen mit dem ST Freiburg in Deutschland. Natürlich ist Freiburg da nochmal ein Stück weiter voraus. Die sind ja mit Christian Streich schon länger ziemlich erfolgreich unterwegs. Haben wir aber auch jetzt mit dem neuen Stadion sich natürlich nochmal ein finanzielles extra Polster geschaffen. Da kommt natürlich auch, obwohl das natürlich zum ersten Mal eine Ausgabe ist, aber es kommt natürlich jetzt auch viel Geld rein, kontinuierlich. Und sie schaffen es tatsächlich auch so, wie gesagt, eine gute Stimmung im Team zu haben, dass viele Spieler vielleicht auch bei anderen Vereinen nicht so gut spielen würden wie vielleicht in Ostersuna. Es ist relativ ruhig, sie können in Ruhe arbeiten. Und wie gesagt, haben einen hervorragenden Trainer. Und das passt im Moment wirklich sehr gut zusammen.
Und geht damit auch ein eigener Spielstil einher? Gibt es Dinge, die Ostersuna auch da anders macht als andere Teams?
Also Ostersuna war in den letzten Jahren eigentlich eher bekannt, oder sagen wir mal, vor diesem Trainerbeginn sehr einsatzfreudig immer zu sein, aber eher so, was die Defensivarbeit anbelangt. Und da war spielerisch jetzt eigentlich nicht so der lecker Bissen. Aber sie haben inzwischen auch dort sich stark verbessert. Haben da wirklich ein paar gute Spieler mit Jimmy Avila vorne in Argentinien. Ein sehr interessanten Stürmer, den kennen vielleicht noch einige aus diversen Strangen Interviews. Er war mal ein sehr armer Schlucker in Argentinien. War da auch auf der Verbrecherschiene so ein bisschen unterwegs. Hatte eine schwere Verletzung und hat es aber dann trotzdem geschafft, jetzt Profi zu werden. Und hat viele Angebote übrigens auch von Top-Clubs in den letzten Jahren. Hat sich aber entschieden, bei Osasuna zu bleiben, weil sie ihm eben die Chance gegeben haben. Und er zahlt das im Moment mit sehr starken Leistungen zurück und eben auch Toren.
War Jemi Avila der Spieler, der mit 13 Jahren sich sein erstes Tattoo selbst gestochen hat?
Ich glaube, das war er, ja. Und hat auch dann eben Kollegen über den Tisch gezogen und so weiter. War halt hartes Überleben in Argentinien. Er hat auch selbst gesagt, dass er da viel Mist gebaut hat. Und naja, er ist jetzt sehr dankbar, sagen wir mal, über seine zweite Chance im Leben. Und ja, wie gesagt, hat jetzt bevorzugt, bei diesem Club zu bleiben, weil er dort wirklich befreit arbeiten kann. Und er möchte dem Club auch ein bisschen was zurückzahlen, dass er eben dieses Vertrauen ausgesprochen bekommen hat vom Verein.
Ich habe übrigens untertrieben. Es war schon mit zehn Jahren das erste Vertrauen. Ich werde mal ein Porträt dazu verlinken. Er hat sich übrigens das Wappen von Rosario damals tätowiert. Also da der Fußballbezug auch da sehr, sehr interessantes. Der war erst einmal bei ESPN erschienen. Da habe ich mich jetzt eben gerade noch dran erinnert. Also da hat man einen Charakter. Wie wird das denn eigentlich in La Liga dann betrachtet? Ist das eine Willkommene Abwechslung von den immer gleichen Geschichten? Oder immer gleich ist jetzt ein bisschen zu viel. Da widersprechen auch die Ligatouren der letzten Saison. Aber es konzentriert sich ja logisch, weil sie dann doch immer auf die großen zweieinhalb, vielleicht auch großen drei. Ist das ein größeres Thema?
Noch nicht. Und ich denke auch, es wird relativ schnell wieder verfliegen, weil ich auch davon ausgehe, dass Osasuna sich dort nicht lange halten wird. Es gibt immer dann so kurze Momentaufnahmen. Da wird man kurz gefeiert und da bekommt man kurz Medienaufmerksamkeit. Aber morgen wird schon wieder alles von basa, unreal und den üblichen Verdächtigen übertüncht werden. Aber für Osasuna ist es auf jeden Fall eine schöne Momentaufnahme. Und wenn sie es tatsächlich mittel- oder langfristig schaffen sollten, dann eben vielleicht so etwas aufzubauen wie der SC Freiburg in Deutschland, dann wird es mit Sicherheit auch mit der Medienaufmerksamkeit anders sein. Aber im Moment denke ich mal eher, es ist eine kurzfristige Lupe, die da über Osasuna, über Pamplona gelegt worden ist. Aber die wird auch schnell wieder verschwinden, sobald der sportliche Erfolg ausbleibt.
Umso schöner, dass wir das jetzt auch hier an dieser Stelle getan haben. Und auch das zweite Thema, das du mitgebracht hast, lenkt den Blick noch nicht auf die großen zwei, nur indirekt. Denn du hast mir geschrieben, und ich zitiere hier, das möchte ich betonen, Betis ist die neue Nummer 1 in Spanien. Bitte was?
Die neue Nummer 1 der normalen Teams, sage ich jetzt mal in Ad-Filmzeichen. Denn nach Real Madrid und Barcelona kommt ja lange Zeit nichts. Atletico Madrid wollen wir da vielleicht, kann man eventuell noch mit reinrechnen, aber auch die haben nicht das hohe Standing, wie diese ersten Bayern-Vereine. Und dementsprechend ist quasi Real Betis im Moment die erste Mannschaft in Spanien, der nicht galaktischen. Es liegt auch hier, glaube ich, wieder vor allen Dingen am Trainer, an Manuel Pellegrini, der dort auch jetzt schon ein paar Jahre kontinuierlich arbeiten kann. Er hat sich da ein Team zusammengestückelt, das wirklich Freude macht. Und er hatte trotz so großen Problemen in der Vorbereitung. Betis hatte nämlich bis zum Transfermarkt-Schluss Probleme, drei oder vier Neuzugänge einzuschreiben. Das war in Spanien ein riesen Theater, bis alle Vereine es geschafft haben, aufgrund des Celery Cups alle Spiele einschreiben zu können. Dementsprechend war Betis, glaube ich, auch die ersten vier Spiele nur mit dem Dreiviertel-Kader unterwegs. Aber sie schaffen es eben auch innerhalb der Mannschaft, eine tolle Stimmung zu haben. Sie haben da so ein paar Vögel in den Reihen, wie zum Beispiel Joaquín, der ist jetzt schon 41, aber der ist einfach… 41, ja. Er spielt auch nicht mehr viel. Aber er ist einfach dafür da, in der Mannschaft Stimmung zu haben. Man sieht das auch immer in den Social-Media-Kanälen, die Betis auch sehr einzigartig betreibt, wie das Team miteinander umgeht, wie sie zusammen lachen, feiern, essen, sonst irgendwas machen. Und natürlich, wenn dann gleichzeitig der sportliche Erfolg auch da ist, dann geht das natürlich hervorragend. Und Pellegrini ist tatsächlich auch ein Übungsleiter, der in schwierigen Situationen es schafft, die Spieler zu schützen. Er war ja mal bei unserem FC Malaga-Trainer, als wir Champions League gespielt haben und ins Viertelfinale damals eingezogen sind. Und auch dort gab es große Probleme. Der Schalke hat die Spieler monatelang nicht bezahlt. Und Pellegrini hat das trotzdem geschafft, die Mannschaft zusammenzuhalten, eine gute Stimmung zu erzeugen. Und gemeinsam haben sie dann quasi eine gewisse Stärke entwickelt aus dieser schwierigen Situation. Ja, und das gelingt ihnen bei Bettis auch wunderbar. Und sie haben wirklich auch sehr, sehr gute Einzelspiele in ihren Reihen. Also ich denke mal, Bettis ist für mich, war ja vor der Saison schon unter den Top-6 auf jeden Fall gesetzt. Und wer weiß, vielleicht klappt es dieses Jahr sogar mit der Champions League.
Hey, wenn ich da jetzt mal so oberflächlich drauf gucke, dann sehe ich allerdings sehr viele erfahrene Spieler, würde ich es jetzt mal nennen. Also William Carvalho, 30 Jahre, Sabali, 29, Guido Rodriguez, Iglesias, 29, 28, 31, Seato Canales und so weiter und so fort. Also relativ wenige junge Spieler. Hat das jetzt auch damit zu tun, dass ich hier gerade in der Ansicht bin, wo nach Spielzeit und nach bisheriger Leistung sortiert wird und da manche noch nicht eingeschrieben waren? Oder ist das noch ein Charakteristikum von Bettis?
Also es gibt natürlich schon noch ein paar Junge, die vielleicht noch nicht eingeschrieben waren, wie zum Beispiel Luis Henrique, der Brasilianer, der am Anfang erst so kam, der jetzt glaube ich erst dieses Wochenende sein erstes Spiel gemacht hat.
Gleich ein Assist?
Ja, genau, gleich ein Assist. Aber du hast schon recht, es sind sehr viele Erfahrungen da, aber es gibt auch ein paar Junge. Es gibt zum Beispiel Rodri aus dem offensiven Mittelfeld von Bettis, der das Tor glaube ich jetzt auch gemacht hat am Wochenende, der viel Spielzeit bekommt. Und ja, da stimmt einfach die Mischung im Moment, muss ich sagen, sehr gut. Und natürlich ist es einfacher, erfahrene Spiele zu führen, auch durch so schwierige Zeiten, die dann vielleicht auf die paar Jungen noch mitnehmen. Und wie gesagt, da ist was Schönes zusammengewachsen bei Sevilla.
Wie sieht der Fußball aus? Man kann ja Pellegrini-Mannschaften immer ganz gut angucken, wenn ich mich da richtig erinnere. Doch, absolut.
Es ist eine kontrollierte Offensive. Es ist kein Hauruck-Fußball, wir gehen nach vorne und pressen ganz, ganz vorne drauf, sondern es ist eher schon so ein bisschen abwarten, dann aber bei Ballgewinn wird natürlich auch extrem schnell umgeschaltet und da haben sie natürlich schon auch Spieler, wie zum Beispiel Canales, den du angesprochen hast, oder Nabil Fekir, die dann eben dann den tödlichen Pass spielen können. Und vorne haben sie eigentlich mit Borja Iglesias, im Moment einen der besten Spanischen Stürmer. Der trifft zumindest in den letzten Monaten, wie er lustig ist. Mit Juanmi haben sie jetzt einen, der sich leider verletzt hat, schwer. Der hat in den letzten Jahren auch vor allen Dingen mit seiner Schnelligkeit viele gefährliche Situationen rausgespielt. William José ist da, der auch jetzt eingeschrieben werden konnte. Der hat aber jetzt in der Europa League getroffen, auch zweimal. Also da ist schon Potenzial da. Und wie gesagt, das Umschaltspiel ist ziemlich gut. Ansonsten würde ich sagen, eine kontrollierte Offensive mit schnellem Umschaltspiel.
Iglesias, gerade auf Platz drei der Torschützenliste, auf Platz zwei Iago Aspas von Celta Vigo und auf Platz eins ein gewisser Robert Lewandowski mit sechs Toren in vier Einsätzen. Und damit sind wir beim letzten Thema. Jetzt geht es dann doch nochmal am Schluss um die großen zwei. Du hast überschrieben, Lewa ballert bei Barca, Real marschiert easy vorneweg. Was müssen wir zu Real und Barca wissen?
Ja, Real gefällt mir jetzt noch nicht so richtig gut bisher, aber sie machen es relativ souverän und easy going. Ohne jetzt groß das Feuerwerk abzubrennen. Benzema ist auch noch überhaupt nicht in Form, hat sich ja auch nochmal verletzt. Aber es reicht qualitativ einfach im Moment dicke nach wie vor in La Liga und in der Champions League werden wir es ja dann auch sehen. Da sind sie ja nochmal extrem gereizt, die Königlichen, wenn es dann wirklich aufs europäische Parkett geht. Also nee, im Endeffekt hat Angelotti den Kader der letzten Saison beigebehalten und punktuell verstärkt den Abgang von Casimiro mit –ich kann den Namen immer nicht aussprechen –Choumeni oder so ähnlich. Dem jungen Franzosen aus Monaco, der auch einen wahnsinnig guten Eindruck bisher hinterlässt, hat jetzt am Wochenende nicht gespielt. Das erste Mal ist geschont worden, ist aber einer der stärksten Spieler schon bei Real Madrid. Kamar Winger ist einer, der da eben nachdrücken kann. Also im Endeffekt haben sie den Kader nur leicht, aber punktuell verstärkt, oder was heißt leicht? Wenig verstärkt, was die Anzahl der Spieler anbelangt, aber eben sehr, sehr, sehr gut auf jeder Position. Und im Endeffekt ist es das Große der letzten Jahre mit Ancelotti vorne dran. Die führen sich im Moment, hat man so das Gefühl, fast von alleine und spazieren da so durch die Liga, fünf Spiele, fünf Siege, auch gegen Betis Sevilla. Da war es mal kurz eins zu eins, aber dann hatte man dann doch das Zwei zu eins erzählen können und hat das Spiel dann auch nach Hause gebracht. Also Real marschiert da vorne weg, ohne sich jetzt bisher große Strecken haben zu müssen. Und Barcelona wird dieses Jahr tatsächlich wieder auf Augenhöhe mit Real Madrid sein. Und unter anderem eben dank Robert Lewandowski, denn der macht eigentlich genau da weiter, wo aber Bayern aufgehört hat. Nämlich, ja, jeder Ball, den er in Straufland bekommt und mehr oder weniger aus Tor bekommt, ist eigentlich fast drin. Ich denke mal, die spanische Liga kommt ihm da auch zugute, denn Spanier sind, glaube ich, vor allen Dingen für einen schönen Offensivfußball bekannt. Nicht unbedingt die defensiv akribischsten Arbeiter. Und ich denke mal, wie gesagt, Lewandowski gegen die Mannschaften 8 bis Platz 20. Wenn er dann einen Ball eben im Straufraum hat, dann hat er keine große Mühe bisher, da seine Tore zu erzielen. Und er ist bereits der gefeierte Held in Barcelona. Die lieben ihn bereits sehr. Alle, die ich auch kenne hier, die Spanier, die mich kennen und die auch wissen, dass ich normalerweise Bayern München sehr gerne verfolge, weil ich aus der Gegend komme, die klopfen mir auf die Schulter und bedanken sich nochmal persönlich bei mir, dass wir ihn zu Barcelona verkauft haben. Also, die sind sehr, sehr happy. Und haben aber auch natürlich noch ein paar andere neue Spieler geholt. Also, Barcelona ist für mich tatsächlich dieses Jahr wieder auf Augenhöhe. Und ich denke, in der Hinsicht haben wir wahrscheinlich zumindest einen interessanten Zweikampf, was dann das Titelrennen anbelangt dieses Jahr.
Wir nehmen jetzt natürlich auch auf an dem Tag, an dem am Abend auch Bayern gegen Barca antreten wird. Ich will jetzt nicht irgendwie das Spiel vorwegnehmen, das ist kaum zu prognostizieren. Was mir allerdings aufgefallen ist, war eine –ich würde es dann doch schon gewisse Überheblichkeit nennen –in der Rezeption der Medien, dass man jetzt erneut wieder gegen Barca spielt. Kann das sein, dass noch nicht alle mitbekommen haben, dass das Barca aus dem letzten Jahr und auch das von vor zwei Jahren vielleicht gar nicht mehr so viel leistungstechnisch mit dem zu tun hat, wie Barca jetzt auftritt?
Da sollte man wirklich gewarnt sein, denn heute kommt ein ganz anderes Barca in die Allianz Arena. Ich denke, auch unter Xavi haben sie sich vor allem defensiv verbessert. Da haben sie auch noch die eine oder andere Verpflichtung gemacht. Es wird nicht einfach, es wird kein Spaziergang. Ich finde im Mittelfeld sehr, sehr interessant die jungen Spanier, Pedro und Gavi, die sind unwahrscheinlich krasse Talente. Beide werden dort über Jahre dominieren, werden so ein bisschen das Xavi und Iniesta der jetzigen Zeit werden.
Der eine ist 19, Pedro ist 18.
Die sind unglaublich. Schaut euch die heute Abend an, oder wenn ihr mal die Chance habt, ein Barca-Spiel zu sehen. Es ist wirklich unglaublich, was die schon in dem Alter für eine Spielgewitztheit haben und auch was für eine Ruhe sie bereits dem Spiel aufdrücken können, wenn es eben gebraucht wird. Hinten haben sie dann noch den Busquets, der dann auch durch seine Erfahrung die Bälle schön verteilt. Und natürlich Frenkie de Jong, der nicht Barca verlassen wollte, obwohl er ja zu so einem Wechsel überredet werden sollte. Denn Barca hat ja auch Geld gebraucht im Sommer. Der hat sich aber auch gedacht, hey, jetzt bin ich seit zwei Jahren bei Barca, jetzt gibt es endlich ein wettbewerbsfähiges Spiel.
Kaum macht es Spaß hier zu sein.
Und bekommt jetzt seine Einsatzzeit und macht das auch richtig gut. Also Barca hat abwehrmäßig, mittelfeldmäßig und im Sturm natürlich im Moment extrem sich verbessert. Und das wird heute Abend eine ganz enge Kiste, glaube ich.
Wir werden es ja dann verfolgen. Und dann sind wir mal gespannt, Fabian. Ich danke dir sehr, sehr herzlich für deine Zeit. Fabian Pakulat, der Ed-Rosengartler, auf Twitter. Danke dir, dass du im Rasenfunk mit dabei warst.
Ja, hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Und bis zum nächsten Mal. Viele Grüße.
Genau, bis zum nächsten Mal. Und an dieser Stelle dann auch nochmal herzlichen Dank an die anderen Gäste, die ihr vorhin schon hören konntet. Ich hoffe, euch hat diese Ligatour gefallen. Hinterlasst uns gerne Feedback auf mitmachen.rasenfunk.de und hört auch gerne die Schlusskonferenzen. Unter anderem ist da erschienen eine Vorschau auf die Frauen-Bundesligasaison. Die möchte ich euch sehr ans Ohr legen. Bei mir war es wieder so, je mehr ich mich mit den Teams beschäftigt habe, desto größer ist die Vorfreude auf diese neue Saison geworden, die ihr jetzt am Freitag schon startet. Also hört auch die Schlusskonferenz und dann bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Ciao!